[Music]
everybody welcome back to grapefruit
this is an interesting episode I think
it's actually it was a little fun since
I get to experiment with a lot of things
that I don't normally get to experiment
with since most of my videos revolve
around either scenery or a cursor
building and this is a completely
generic coaster how it's named
grapefruit so I wouldn't really expect
anything from it but it does allow me to
experiment with more generic things that
aren't tied to a theme so I'll be
playing around a lot with terraforming
and foliage and in general trying to
make this look as realistic as I can so
without further ado let's get into the
tablet
all right so the first thing that I
wanted to start off with is some Terra
bending one of the things which I
actually really like about the way that
the deck is work together I'm not sure
to what extent this was on purpose by
the developers or to what extent this is
just a bit of a weird afterthought but
one of the things that I really like
about the way that Texas is interact is
the way that certain textures cannot
overlap there are some tech students
that really mix together and some
textures that almost repel each other
and that you can barely overlap until
you're really dragging up the intensity
which means if you have a very low
intensity and especially a large brush
size and you're mixing different
textures together that repel each other
or that mix together you can actually
get these very interesting fields and
clashes between textures which in this
case since I'm working with send
textures I was hoping we'd sort of make
the ground look like you're getting this
this drifting sand and this mix of sand
and soil in a sort of uneven way in the
area as you would kind of have with a
semi-arid climates underneath a
rollercoaster where there isn't really
so much gardening
because this is this is actually
something that has always sort of been
something that I've been noticing is
that a lot of coaches get very lush
foliage around it you see scenery
everywhere but in real life we also have
our parks like six legs which don't
really put anything around
rollercoasters that just keep it to the
roller coasters themselves and keep the
ground underneath the roller coasters
either just grass or just some sand and
mud or in the worst case scenario just a
parking lots now I don't know I don't
quite want to go as far as putting this
coaster over a parking lot at something
that I think just by yeah Muir I'm not
sure of dignity is the right word but
Mero merely by self-respect I don't want
to build a coaster on a parking lot but
I didn't want to play around more with
the idea of a courser that isn't so
touched up everywhere of course so
that's really about the coaster itself
and where you can tell that the
landscape otherwise hasn't really been
meddled with and it's just left over to
the elements which in this case the
coaster is supposedly placed somewhere
in a semi-arid climates somewhere around
the Mediterranean probably so it gets a
similar sort of landscape thanks to that
now I'll be playing around a little bit
more with that on the later stage when
I'm getting the foliage in but first I
also wanted to experiment a bit with
fences and paths so I'm bringing in some
custom path textures just to make the
part a little bit more flexible and make
it look at it a little bit more organic
as well sort of the way that it flows
around the coaster but also some custom
fences and one of the pieces that
actually fell in love with are these hot
wall pieces which you're supposed to use
for stations because they they open up a
gap which the station platform can go
through and when you're building a wall
around your station but in this case
they actually work out perfectly for
paths since one half of the wall is
actually invisible on the ground and the
other half is like the two meters that
are actually above ground which means
that if you're rotating it you actually
stay perfectly connected to the wall
that you place before it so it actually
saves you a lot of time because usually
if you're building then
or path curves like this you have to
constantly make the walls fit together
but if you're using this wall you can
actually just shift it half a meter or
half a grid grid space I suppose
if you've placed the wall before it's
then rotated and it will stay perfectly
connected to the wall before it so that
was a neat little trick and also I
wanted to get a bit more into some
simple custom fences which is just iron
fences keeping the people out of the
area where the cursor goes but they are
also quite fancy I suppose they do have
some decoration in the form of some
stone pillars over there and of course
there's some foliage around the area as
well now I want to take a little bit of
time as I'm building the entrance sign
to to plug a series that I've liked
before but not in this sense to plug
planet bro coaster because it's an
amazing series but one of my favorite
videos coming out of it recently was bro
basics number 2 which is about foliage
and landscaping and it's a really good
tutorial actually you might not be able
to tell from the title but it's a
tutorial on doing foliage and it doesn't
so much go into detail exactly building
all kinds of foliage but more general
rules of thumb and patterns that you
should keep in mind when you're doing
your foliage one thing that I thought
was particularly interesting that I
never really thought about before and
something that really starts to make
sense of you here in the name is they
brought in the word nature which stands
for nature that's not really nature it's
man-made but it supposedly kind of looks
like nature it's a little bit organic
it's a little bit random it's all
planted and it's all put on well once
it's on the show it's all presented to
the guests of the park in a beautiful
manner as possible but at the same time
it's trying to be natural it isn't
natural because it's completely man-made
and it's all neatly arranged in that
sense but it's trying to be quite
natural so that's something which I
actually put a little bit in these
bushes although this was recorded a long
before that tutorial came out I
definitely recommend what you mean
because watching it will probably
instantly improve your your foliage
skills if you can call it that it
definitely did for me even though I've
been at this kind of stuff for many
years so I greatly recommend watching
that video but especially the point
about nature was something that I
thought was very interesting that the
very basic premise is that you've got
actual nature which is just completely
natural and honestly often quite boring
then there is the nature the man-made
nature which looks like nature is a
little bit more organic but also a bit
more interesting and blunted and then
there's the actual completely man-made
foliage which you'll see around Punk
like Epcot's which is the gardening
really lines of flowers or perfectly
lined trees things where you can very
easily tell that it's man-made but it's
still quite neat as well but these are
three types to keep in mind and as a
general other rule of thumb to keep in
mind about them is that they're also
increasingly expensive so one thing that
came up earlier in broker sir is that
color is expensive than green is cheap
so putting flowers everywhere and neatly
arranged patterns is beautiful but the
average park will not be able to
actually afford all of that and nature
is a little bit more expensive than
nature but looks a bit nicer in your
acquired as well anyway with all that
said about body trying to catch up
really badly so what I did in the time
that I was talking about foliage is I
built a quick sign saying great fruit in
the same colors as the coaster because
that's it's kind of a bit of a trend for
generic coasters if you haven't really
got anything to theme it around I
suppose you can just give the fences and
accents of buildings around the collar
or around the coaster the same colors as
the coaster itself and at least there's
a very clear visual connection between
the coaster and the scenery around it
even if it's very cheap and simple so
we've got that in same kind of goes for
the fences as I'm just adding some very
basic detailing to the queue again this
is all
also very cheap ideas the idea would be
that if grapefruit were to exist in a
real park it's not the cheapest coaster
since it is bnm but it's not really it's
not really the Disney world of this of
this world so it's more something like
it six legs coaster or something like
that so would definitely be theme very
easily and in a cheap way
so the queue pretty much just exists of
some tenses to keep you inside the queue
and some very basic keep scenery like
some barrels being thrown around some
oil drums
I suppose they actually are and tires
there is no specific theme to this
coaster so it's religious some random
clutter but I think it works to at least
make the queue a little bit more
interesting and realistically a huge
should probably just be very boring for
a coaster like this as much as I am NOT
a fan of boring queues it's something
that in some parks I suppose you really
can't escape them unfortunately now here
I'm getting to the sign of the coaster
which in hindsight is something that I'm
not and clearly happy with it's it for
one it's a very unreadable sign for the
size of the box you can get much smaller
letters with the eyepieces than this
that are much more readable but I
figured I would just go with this weird
sort of slanted modern style because
perhaps I suppose it fits the edginess
of the coaster and it's a little bit
over the top like that and the standard
generic industrial like that as well
but it's it's a bit strange so I might
think about that sign a little bit more
and complain about it a little bit more
but I'm probably not going to change it
because I'm too lazy to do that but it's
a bit of a weird sign it says it's a
strange font I'm not entirely unhappy
about it though I think it looks quite
all right it's just totally readable and
you have to know that it says grapefruit
in order for it to really make sense
there are quite a few letters in there
and which because of the way that
everything is slanted don't really make
as much sense and oh yeah kind of
dressing it up like a cocktail over
there is figured I could just
some grapefruit slices on the corner
because that I suppose I kind of works
it does add some different color to it
but you know it's a sign amout of
grapefruit what am I really going to say
about this actually there is there is
still some some technicalities do this
since I had to make this an actual
support of course so there are some
beams on the back and there is some
interesting structure keeping all of
this up with wooden planks that all have
slightly different colors and or kind of
offset to make it look a little bit more
natural and the same sort of very slight
slant in the the planks as well and at
the back that's the actual structure
that's keeping the sign up or the iron
beams that actually hold up everything
and connect it to the ground so yeah
it's a simple sign it probably could
have been quite a bit better but still
in the end it I think it does fit the
cursor all right so I'll probably keep
it around so with that out of the way I
wanted to get back to this area over
here and do a little bit more of path
work especially some of these fences
these are some of the metallic fences
that I actually hardly use but that are
very common in theme parks to keep
people from going into the area where
the coaster actually goes because
they're hard to climb over and they just
fit the generic style as well if this
were say a jungle ride I would probably
have a log fence or something that's
related to the theme but if your coaster
is generic or at least generic enough
I think metallic senses are really the
best option since this is really safety
not scenery and the biggest priority
safety should always be number one
priority but the biggest priority is
keeping the guests safe of course so and
some metallic sensors over here and
actually did leave some space between
the fence and the curb of the path to
put in some very simple foliage as well
so I'm actually pretty happy with that
I actually forgot to mention one quick
tip about foliage that will make your
foliage it's ten times better believe me
team point designers will hate you for
this one it's just to make the ground
underneath the foliage muddy and soily
instead of just leaving it gross or
scent especially if you have a grants
park just adding a bit of soil texture
underneath your foliage can make a world
of difference especially if it's really
the sort of planter like arrangement
that I have going on here along the side
of a pod it just adds a bit to the
realism and makes it actually look like
it's it's supposed to be there instead
of being some sort of weed so yeah we've
we have some very simple shrubs being
put there obviously in the area of the
coaster itself I don't quite want to
make the foliage as heavy but I still
wanted to put a bit of foliage over
there because of it it was still working
a little bit too empty otherwise also
something that I experimented with quite
a bit over here that I have been
experimenting with before but never
really showed off in a video is the idea
of actually putting poor grass into
parks I quite like the idea of tall
grass because I just like the idea of 3d
graphs and it's one of the things that I
sort of miss and planet coaster although
understandably it would totally totally
ruin the performance of a quark you
cannot have an entire theme park with 3d
grass everywhere but still it's
something that I really like the idea of
so I've always been experimenting a
little bit with 3d grass and one of the
best methods I think that works for it
is this yellow flower that you can
recolor and flower is kind of look like
grass sprites so if you actually color
the flower not in a flower color does
that make any sense but into a dark
Gracia green you can actually have
something that looks a lot like cross
and that's something that I'll be
singing quite a bit into the ground to
add all these any sprites of grass here
in there it's not something that really
works that well if you want to make an
entire field of grass it all for one
really lag because you're going to get
tens of thousands of bushes very quickly
I tried this and it didn't really work
that well but at least you can get some
small sprites here in there to have some
large grass Tufts
which is quite nice and something that
adds a bit of depth into your ground
shrubbery because in many cases you
don't really want to have ground sugar
everywhere but you don't want to leave
your areas completely bare like just
some sand or completely flat grass I
think it's quite boring as well so
adding these small Tufts here in there
at least add some texture and depth to
those areas where you can't really put
anything else
it also comes back to the idea of just
being natural scenery and not something
that's really maintained by anybody so
it's just gonna it's just going to over
grow and have lots of large grass in the
field and that's definitely something
that I wanted to have with this coaster
as well although maybe maybe someday
I'll actually try and pick something
with a complete field of 3d graphs or
perhaps one day frontier might edit
really sure if that's a great idea but
if it works it would be really amazing
but for now I'm actually quite happy
just adding small cuts of grass here and
there speaking of front here there's
actually some interesting news that I've
been wanting to talk about I'm not
entirely sure how much I'm allowed to
say this right from here but I like to
say it anyway so basically you might
know that frontier does watch a lot of
videos and all kinds of other content
that comes out about planet coaster and
it has really influenced the way that
the game develops and like they like to
say it's a game that was almost in parts
built by the community itself because
the community really shaped what the
game what directions the game takes so
in that spirit knowing that my fear is
also getting watched quite a bit spike
from to your employees mm-hmm I would
like to kind of admit that I started
this coaster to complain a little bit
the coaster creator in the game the same
kind of goes for the smooth college
planet coaster college coaster tutorial
the the smooth coasters planet coaster
college tutorial there we go because
it's it's something that's been
bothering me for a while I still like
their the coaster creator as a whole but
just the transitions between the
different notes the fact that it likes
continuous roll and that it likes a
heartline our issues that have been
bothering me quite a bit because they
because the creator could be almost
perfect at least it could be perfect but
right now it's like they just didn't
dare to take the last steps to make it
perfect and finding some kind of
solution and we honest I'm not entirely
sure myself what it would be to get the
coaster creator to be more smooth and
resolve the issue where you don't notice
anymore when the coaster goes from one
node to the other one track piece to the
other that would be amazing and that's
one of the reasons why I started this
coaster is a bit of an experiment to see
how smooth things actually can go in
planet coaster what the issues are and
what a course would actually look like
if it were a lot more smooth than the
standard Costa Creator actually allows
us to do the same kind of goes to the
camera as well because one of the
reasons that this method does work out
is the fact that the camera anticipates
different track pieces so it really
moves in this weird way which works out
in its advantage in this coaster since
the track pieces are all four meters so
and there are very subtle movements that
make the coaster look a bit smoother but
in general the camera and the course
creator being quite unsmooth or some of
my major gripes with the game but the
good news that I wanted to talk about is
that this has actually been delayed to
the frontier offers quite a bit because
recently I've seen the Community
Managers actually go on to discord and
take a lot of ideas and recommendations
and requests from a lot of different
people and one of the most common
requests was to make the coaster creator
smoother and fix some of the issues that
have been talking about in my recent
videos
and that have just been going around the
community as well in general because I
don't know make it seem like it's just
an issue that's coming from me it's just
personally for me it's one of my biggest
gripes and things that I would like to
see changed but it's now at frontier and
the idea is there and we'll see if it
gets picked up if in the future
something happens I've recently seen a
video by a very variable gaming which
I'll link in the description where he
talked about the sank that coasters have
seemed to get smoother it wasn't
entirely sure what it was but something
apparently has happened that has make
things smoother and to be honest I'm not
entirely sure what it is either it's a
very subtle change in the camera it
appears but yeah it's good to see that
stuff is happening and they know about
the issues and also like you said things
right now are quite a bit better
actually than in the first alphas so
though it definitely is an upward curve
in that sense also I'm going to sort of
link that video because I've been
needing to shout how shout out his
channel in quite a while because he
makes some really amazing smooth
coasters and pretty much every day he
has a coaster coming out so I definitely
go check out his channel actually make
some awesome stuff now finalizing my
video over here it's just mostly pass
works which is a little bit boring
I suppose especially to do it since it
takes quite a bit of effort to do it
this way but I just wanted to have some
subtle changes in part works over here
and make the layout a little bit more
fluid and organic and also have some
slightly different textures what you'll
often notice around theme parks
especially the theme parks that choose
to go for some of the cheaper methods of
doing their Park System and just go for
concrete and asphalt sand tarmac is that
you have like the split of slightly
different textures you either see
different large plates of concrete or
have slightly different colored asphalt
textures stuff like that but very subtle
changes in park texture it's something
that you don't really have implant
coasters since you just have a limited
array of path textures that are all
clean and perfect but it's the sort of
in
perfection of the part that I wanted to
try and get in here a little bit well at
the same time also changing the layout
of the part a bit as well I'm not sure
if I'm actually going to use this space
to build a building because it's
definitely a Plaza that seems built in a
way that it needs something at the end
of it like this cannot just be an exit
path Plaza but that said I'm not really
sure how far I'm going to go in that's
because this is this was grapefruit and
the focus is on the coaster itself and
to be very honest I don't really want to
build an entire park around grapefruit
now we take way too much time I don't
think it's really worth it
and this is mostly an experiment in the
coaster builder and trying to build a
semi realistic coaster almost applica
which though it is definitely not a
standard bnm layouts but that's that's
an entirely different discussion which I
guess I could go into for a little bit
there's the discussion between making
realistic courses there are some people
that really like to make courses based
on the exact layouts that they have in
real life and make some variations on
that while on the other end of the
spectrum there are people that make
complete fantasy coasters that don't
really base themselves on manufacturers
and what kind of layouts and shaping of
the track they have and I feel like I
like exists somewhere in the middle
between words and it's interesting
because it's a topic that I rarely talk
about but something which i think is
really a signature of what I like to do
is that it's somewhat based in reality
it's a course that could be built by the
manufacturer and it's at least
believable to that extent but it's
definitely completely different layouts
and there's no B&M flawless that really
looks like this although some people
have said it looks a lot like
hair-raising which is fair definitely
with that color scheme and although this
was entirely accidental it looks a lot
like grapevine in roller coaster green
one I didn't even intend that as as some
sort of obscure reference but I'll
definitely take it
I love grapevine and never during this
building did I ever did it ever occur to
me that it looks about my grade point so
that was just a coincidence
but still grapevine is awesome Campbell
acoustic rune is awesome so up I
intended that reference I'll say anyway
that's in it for this episode so thank
you guys for watching and staying
through all my strange rents and I'll
end the video with a quick cinematic
shots and hopefully I'll see you guys in
the next and the last episode of
grapefruit
[Music]